we already have several videos talking
about the byzantine empire which is
really just the continuation of the
roman empire after its fall and they
even call themselves the roman empire
but what i want to do in this video is a
bit of a deep dive to make sure we
understand the different elements of
continuity and change between what we
consider the roman empire when it was
one unified western and eastern roman
empire and then what we later call the
byzantine empire so what was the same
between them and then what changed over
time
so let's just do a review this is what
things look like at around the year 400.
as you can see from an administrative
point of view even though it was
considered one empire it was already
being governed separately the west being
governed from rome the east being
governed from constantinople and most
historians mark the beginning of the
byzantine empire with the rule of
constantine who moves the capital to
byzantium it gets renamed constantinople
but as we've talked about in multiple
videos in 476
you have the fall of the western roman
empire and the west becomes fragmented a
bunch of various germanic kingdoms but
the eastern roman empire with its
capital at constantinople continues and
once again they did not call themselves
the byzantines they call themselves the
romans they call themselves the roman
empire it was only much much later that
historians tried to separate this period
of the roman empire by calling it the
byzantine empire
there is a bit of a resurgence under
justinian he's able to capture
significant portions of the west
including the italian peninsula
but then over time the byzantine empire
contracts especially in the east it has
to contend with the spread of islam
as we go even further in time as we
enter into the second millennium we can
see that the muslim turks make further
inroads into the byzantine empire also
during the fourth crusades western
crusaders sack constantinople
and we can go all the way to 1453
where all that was left at the time of
the byzantine empire or you could say
the eastern roman empire is
constantinople and in 1453 that also
gets sacked by the ottomans and that's
the official end of the byzantine empire
the eastern roman empire which you can
see continues on for another thousand
years after the fall of the western
roman empire
now with that review out of the way
let's think about how the byzantine
empire was the same and different from
the roman empire
so first let's think about the center of
power well the roman empire is named
after its seed of power during the great
majority of its history the seed of
power of the roman empire is rome near
the end of the western roman empire it
becomes ravenna and of course we talk
about constantine changing the capital
to byzantium which eventually became
constantinople and that's the official
start of at least the roots of the
byzantine empire although constantine
was emperor of both it's fair to say
that rome was the capital of the roman
empire from its early days as a kingdom
all the way until the first several
centuries of the common era the roots of
the byzantine empire are with
constantine changing the capital the
seed of power of the combined empire and
moving it from rome to byzantium which
will eventually be called
constantinople now let's think about
language so the language of the roman
empire is latin in the early days of the
byzantine empire latin is used in
conjunction with greek but over time it
becomes more greek in fact heraclius in
the 7th century makes greek the official
language of the byzantine empire now
religion for most of roman history their
religion is the roman pantheon
now near the end of what is called the
roman empire when constantine comes
around in the early 4th century
christianity gets legalized and
theodosius who is the last emperor to
rule over both east and west he makes
christianity the official religion
since the eastern roman empire's roots
the byzantine empire's roots are
considered to be with constantine it has
a christian nature from the beginning
and it only becomes more and more
christian over time
in other videos we will talk about the
eventual spiritual split between east
and west the latin christian church and
the greek christian church and they're
going to diverge more and more as we go
into the year 1054 when there's the
official great schism in terms of law
the roman empire has a long tradition of
law and i guess we could just call it
the roman
law in fact so profound has its
influence been on western civilization
that many of our legal terms today come
from latin what historians would
consider the byzantine empire would
continue robin law
much of it written in latin justinian
would famously try to reform roman law
make it more consistent make it more
clear tinian's
code and you have the emperor leo iii
has the famous ekloga
but as you have these revisions and
these reformations of roman law they are
more and more written in greek than
latin and they do have more and more of
a christian influence
in terms of governance especially under
the roman empire the notion of a
province
was the main subdivision under which the
empire was governed
once you have emperor diocletian come
onto the scene and this is shortly
before the time of constantine he
reformed it and he set up what is known
as a tetrarchy
where you had these
two emperors of east and west and then
you would have essentially their
subordinate emperors but along with that
he redefined what a province is so you
had smaller
provinces
which then would go into diocese which
would then go into prefix which would
then go into a tetrarch once you have
the start of the byzantine empire they
would have elements of this
constantine remember constantine wasn't
only the byzantine wasn't only the
emperor of the east he was emperor of
both east and west but he got rid of the
tetrarchy but he kept diocletian's
notions of these smaller provinces going
into diocese going into prefix so you
have that continuity but then later on
in the mid seventh century it was turned
into more of a feudal theme system in
the byzantine empire once again this was
under heracles who also made greek the
official language
and the reason why i say it's futile it
was comparable to the feudal system in
western europe at the time
was that it provided land grants to
local rulers in exchange for their
military service and the ability for
them to send resources up to the emperor
in terms of culture you have many of the
things that we associate with the roman
empire you have chariot racing
you have gladiator fights
you have imperial birthdays
you have the olympics which carries over
from the ancient greeks that actually
lasts over a thousand years as we go
into the roman empire
some of these continue and some of them
don't
so for example the notion of chariot
racing does and famously justinian is
almost overthrown after a rowdy chariot
race
you don't have the olympics theodosius
felt that it wasn't in line with
christian tradition
but you did have things like imperial
celebrations imperial
birthdays so the byzantine empire
definitely continued some of the
traditions but also eliminated others
so this is just a rough overview i
encourage you to think about it yourself
are we missing any dimensions and what
other aspects do you think were the same
as we go from the traditional roman
empire into the continuation of the
roman empire which historians will later
call the byzantine empire